I would say exercise like your life
depends on it because it does honestly
if this person was talking say dude I
just don't feel it I'd be like brother
then don't do it for yourself do it for
your wife do it for your children have
some pride in yourself like dig deep man
doesn't you don't have to run marathons
but like you can't walk for 30
minutes a day those little things become
contagious they become it becomes like a
snowball rolling down a mountain it will
gain momentum but it's just like
straight physics a body in motion will
tend to stay in moot and a body at rest
will tend to stay at rest unless acted
upon by an outside force you you're in
control of this like you only have one
life why would you squander and neglect
the greatest gift you could ever
receive like look at what I look at what
people have been able to do with their
bodies get over that that's a
poisonous mindset being lazy is like
yeah I'm lazy I don't want to work well
you ain't going to eat cuz you
ain't going to get paid